now that we're through spring break all
eyes are on summer travel but you may be
doing a double take with gas prices sky
high so what can you do to pinch pennies
our mary jane believa joins us with some
tips to save you may not have even
thought about mary jane good morning
heather good morning and you know what
i'm ready you can see i'm already in
this already
my favorite times of years definitely
with summer around the corner because of
road trip season and i spoke with one
local mechanic who tells me that despite
the high gas prices he is anticipating a
busy travel season ahead for the summer
and i did speak with victor bonari who
is the owner of universal motor cars he
says right now it's a busy time for his
shop with temperatures getting warmer
more people are coming in but nothing
could put a hit on those travel plans
like having your car break down hundreds
of miles from home so if you're planning
to go on that road trip he recommends
you get your car inspected no matter how
far you're going and as you prepare for
your trip he does have a few tips to
help you save money on gas
first of all not to accelerate fast
because when you push the gas pedal you
floor it the injectors pulsate faster
that means more fuel are going inside
the engine that's one tip
another thing is drive with the windows
up
windows darwin will cause a bad fuel
consumption of because of the
aerodynamic inside the
threads
now he says to do your homework plan out
your routes and check gas prices in
advance and back out here live he says
it's also important to ensure your tires
that they're in good shape and full of
air that they're in the right condition
to follow up on your tune-ups and of
course as we all know another important
thing is the air conditioning especially
for those of us who live in vegas we all
know that's really important to make
sure that is up to date as well
reporting live mary jane bellezza live
local now